là có thể giúp thảo lý nghĩa nhà cho thời là công trên gió tổ chức, cá nhân đổ tư để cho thời.
Nhanh nước dưới và cho chù đạo cho việc tạo lập của ý nhà bằng vượn gân xác,
mô đe xuất nhóm được thời, con người thu hưởng chính xác nhà ở xa hội như hộng nhau,
công nhân được lần vú trạng, công chức, sinh gần.
Mọi gia thì cánh bộ, công chức được lần trước và người lao động cũng trong giúp được thời,
thông qua khuy cạnh gió quyết nhà ở cú gia tạo lập.
Được kẹp bắt mục bởi người thời là họ chưa có nhà thực sự hiểu,
họ có nhà tại đi phương, giúp dẫn tích mình con đồng người thì thấp hơn mức tử thiệu,
hồi dò sĩ phục quy định, chù đồng tư dự ám nhà ở trong thời có thể được sang
hành phần trong tổng giữa tích sang cho khi ra dịch vụ thương mại nhằm có một lực
để giảm giá cho thế nhà.
Với tự này cũng được hưởng đại thời giá chỉ ra tăng via tê cho phần dân thú từ việc
của trọt thời.
Về giá thôi thì bộ xây dựng đề xuất vình tắc tình đúng luộng mỗi chi
phía vẫn hành được gà khô hảo, nhưng bộ rại chiến cơ khóa đưa đại tình a nước.
Với nhà thương mại giá phù hợp tại dự hảo thì bộ xây dựng cũng định nghĩa là nhà ở
được xây theo dự án để bán thêm 1, họ chòa thươi thật cơ chế thì chường.
Sản phân nay được nhà nước họ chợ cơ chế và phải đáp ứng các cơ chế về giá.
Bộ đề xuất giá bán thêm 1 của rại nhà ở này giống như bán nhân dân tốt từ
việc kiao tình của vật của hợp để vật khả năng chi trả của bây dân.
Nhưng giá này vẫn phải bảo đảng tính đúng tính đồ của chi phy.
Nhà ở tương mại giá phù hợp cũng có thể bị hảm chế trị đợp.
Cơ quan sợ tạo đi xuất đổi muộ tương nhà không được bán là trong ít nhất là năng năng kể từ ngày thêm tỏa đục tiền.
Đồng thời họ phải là cá nhân trong lước và chỉ được xợ hữu tới ra một cân nhà tại một sự án.